there's data that we have and I don't
know how accurate it is but it tracks
with what I've been already seeing about
Italy and it looks like we in the United
States are literally days maybe even a
week away from a full-on lockdown I'm
hoping I'm wrong yeah I'm hoping I'm
wrong so welcome to the show I'm Tim
what's up everybody at him and we've
we've got it we've got it we still got a
couple segments we're gonna talk a lot
about coronavirus as per usual just
because I mean it's it's literally
dominating everything so if you want to
get in your super chats do so now but
again we're gonna be live just until
before 9:00 and we're gonna we're gonna
hard stop because then the president's
gonna speak and that's gonna be pretty
important so the first thing I wanna
show you is is just I guess literally
the tweet from the president yeah he
says I will be addressing the nation
this evening at 9:00 p.m. Eastern if if
you guys end up watching this later on
as the recorded clip you probably have
already seen what he said but he did
tweet before that I am fully prepared to
use the full power of the federal
government to deal with our current
challenge of the coronavirus and this
seems to be kind of a shift from where
he was before cuz he's he's been
repeatedly saying oh look the flu is so
much worse well maybe it has something
to do with the whu-oh finally going okay
it's it's a pandemic it's a pandemic you
know what you've been saying it's a pain
but you know they definitely said you
know the switch means what when the
World Health Organization officially
went from outbreak to pandemic they were
saying we've lost control that's the
point yeah they didn't want to do that
because they were worried it would spark
panic because an outbreak is like we're
dealing with it pandemic is it's beyond
our control it's it's done so I'm gonna
show you some data and I'm not
completely convinced on it but it does
track similarly to what I've been
looking at now here's here's the issue
this is Eli Pariser I believe his name
is I'm like move on up worthy I
personally don't find him trustworthy I
consider him to be a partisan and I
think there's a lot of people who are
have a vested interest in trying to make
the president look bad by any means
necessary however I do think Trump's you
know talk of the flu virus and stuff was
was weak I don't know I don't maybe weak
in the right word but he was definitely
not playing it strong enough so here's
the thing I don't I don't necessarily
trust this guy but you can look at the
start date for the for the first signs
of u.s. infection and Italy's for us it
was the fourth for Italy it was the 22nd
on moving from day one to three
we tracked very similarly and you can
see we're on day eight or at least
whenever he posted this is three hours
ago
Italy is on day 12 and you can see that
the cases have reached this point then
they fully lock things down now there
are some considerations which could be
worse could be could be good for us
could be bad for us we've got what like
seven times the people that Italy does
yeah I was just thinking about we're
huge that's that could be worse
our country is massive yeah it's gonna
spread faster it's gonna eventually go
higher than then no not that it could be
X it could grow exponentially faster so
we could go like up up up and be higher
spiking yeah by day twelve we might be
double where Italy is because we have
substantially more people mm-hmm so I
don't know exactly what to expect I
really don't the president's gonna speak
we'll see what has to say you know later
on again some of you may have already
seen it but I do want to show you I
think this this might be it so this is
so that that data from Eli I don't know
exactly where he's getting those numbers
um they do track very similarly to the
stories I saw however so I tend to think
it's it's correct but here we have this
is from this is just a sub stack so it's
also it's hard to know for sure
you know what it's hard to verify a lot
of stuff right now because people are
throwing things out there but this shows
basically a graph of deaths and days
since the you know the outbreak in China
and we can see that the Green Line is
Italy and they're on an upward
trajectory so they're projecting it's
gonna get worse and the US here we can
see it's not too dissimilar but we are
lagging behind Italy in terms of how
long we've had active infection rates so
it's entirely possible that we you know
go up past China or I don't really know
but I think I think it's gonna get worse
and I and you know I kind of bounce back
and forth between whether or not things
are chilling out things are getting
crazier I think things are getting
crazier and I think I think what you're
hearing from the experts is a desperate
attempt to try and calm things down yeah
I think it's really bad I think so I was
reading that the infection rate for the
elderly mm-hm like the the average age
of death it's like a 14 percent
mortality no day and in Italy their
mortality rate is like 6 period Wow yeah
that's that's probably why they lock
down like crazy like they were getting
hit really really hard by this so I've
got I've got a couple other things I
want to show you guys
in in in you know what's going on
coronavirus this is a journalist named
Andy Carvin Andy might have it he thinks
he has it I'm not sure where he's at
but he said this is from just a couple
hours ago last Thursday I was admitted
to the ER with coronavirus symptoms
including chronic cough shortness of
breath and lung pain I was given a kovat
19 tests and told I'd have the results
within 40 hour 48 hours nearly a week
later I still don't have the results he
goes through the whole process it's you
know I don't really want to go through
the entirety of his story he just
basically says like here what happened
you know they told me to go home and he
said the guy looked like an you know
what is this an imperial guard from Star
Wars yeah but here's what I want to show
you why this is so serious and I think a
lot of people whether it's whether the
mortality rate is high or not is
completely irrelevant you ready for some
shocking images that are make you upset
what is what are they calling this
they're calling us the ground glass
opacity what you're seeing is lung
damage permanent lung damage whoa this
guy's 44 he died Wow yeah so you're
young so permanent permanent so the flu
doesn't do that not that I'm aware of no
I don't think so I don't know so anyways
to the fluid this is not not respiratory
as far as I know yeah so everyone come
anyone comparing it to the flu it
doesn't make sense to do that anymore
does permanent damage sense no and
that's that's the thing it's like
imagine a known imagine people were like
dude Ebola killed so many people like
it's like well yeah but Ebola didn't
travel so there's so many different
things about this yeah this is what
freaks me out it's like oh okay yeah
well we'll survive and then you're gonna
have what diminished lung capacity for
the rest your life because of scar
tissue in your lungs exactly okay we
know thanks yes ours didn't make it
anywhere the first one back in the 2000
like 2003 or whatever yeah and neither
did MERS I think it was like o 1 and O 3
or whatever I don't know I don't know
yeah this is this is scary
yeah those x-rays that doesn't look very
good man and they're saying this is
someone who actually passed though yeah
this person died okay okay so I mean
there's no saying that a healthy person
that gets over it is going to get
permanent damage or do they have that
everyone yet no I don't know man that's
frightening
yeah well is it worth the risk you want
to buy a lottery ticket to have
permanent lung damage I'm not interested
no but apparently now I'm not going
anywhere there was a there was an
aggression ulm eating Republicans were
told every Americans gonna be exposed to
this well eventually yeah it doesn't
mean that everyone's gonna get it right
but everyone will be exposed some people
won't get sick most people probably will
it's like what so the first thing we
heard last month was experts saying that
they were predicting 60 to 70 percent
global infection rate right what does it
know same thing yeah Merkel is saying
like in Germany they're expecting 60 to
70 percent and now we're hearing similar
things that last week in a meeting
Republicans were told everybody's gonna
get hit by this so it's it that sounds
like a hundred percent not 60 to 70 well
no but like not everyone gets sick oh
right so I I don't know what well gano
hit by like getting knocked off off your
feet yeah I don't know I guess I'm not
entirely sure I know it's it's hard to
know exactly what's going on but what I
can say is they're canceling tons of
events we have we have this story now
it's going viral this is this is the
number two national trend on Twitter
cancel everything yep cancel everything
literal everything social distancing is
the only way to stop the coronavirus we
must start immediately cancel cultures
actually working that was I was actually
someone called it cancel culture
coronavirus or and there was there was a
there was a bunch of hashtags for
they're so funny let's go yeah and they
were saying like cancel everything yeah
cancel everyone and everything shut it
down no more coronavirus so it might be
we're already seeing a bunch of news
organizations ABC it was I think told
their employees not to come to work they
said if you don't have to don't come to
work yeah now activists are saying that
all debts should be deferred for the
duration of the krona virus yeah like
dude we're gonna go into economic
hibernation on this yeah it seems like
it everything just stops didn't didn't
Britain like plan to do something like
that I was reading about it yeah
three-month freeze or something yeah
yeah something dude well it's gonna be a
wild ride I had you guys and you guys
have your board games yeah I hope I hope
you like board games good thing we just
got the pool table set up we got a pool
table yeah we're we're we're setting
things up you know let me let me let me
show you something else that's really
really weird check this out this Suites
started making the rounds you can see i
retweeted it because i know they're
gonna get mad at me if we're tweeting it
because they're gonna call me conspiracy
there's I just retweeted it's
verified nature news they are the it's
the news team at nature the
International Journal of science tweeted
this out November 2015 a lab made bat
coronavirus related to SARS has been
shown to infect human cells oh this is
from 2015
mom 25th and I don't know if they say it
was actually from China but it was
horseshoe bats in China so now people
are already saying like it's China
they're like this is it well I just saw
over your shoulder on the TV over there
that they were reporting about it and
now they're calling it the Chinese
coronavirus oh that's not that I've
never heard that before
racist oh that's fully racist now yeah
where Wuhan virus makes sense because
that's where it's from or supposedly see
that's the thing it's like it's
supposedly from Wuhan so what I don't
you know I'm so over this thing well
it's gonna if it's truly is gonna hit
everybody I mean that what are we gonna
do then we're gonna sit and think we got
water and food and we can just sit and
hunker down yeah well you know here's
the other thing too it's like there are
a lot of the people are being advised
not to go visit family anymore yeah
don't don't was your family don't visit
your parents your grandparents and there
was a reporter who asked governor jay
Inslee I think it's in his Washington
right yeah cuz that because there's
they're banning any public event over
200 people sporting events everything's
shut down Wow and someone asked him
what's the penalty if someone violates
this and he says your grandparents your
grandparents will die
of course yeah is like that's the
penalty let's be real Wow yeah thanks
for checking out this segment from the
Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
every Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more show
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all in
the next show
you